I was a virgin I was 16 years old and
since I was such a novice I thought I
should go I should go to a professional
and I was traveling with a bunch of
friends in Europe we were there were 20
of us in a group and we go to this uh
the red light district in Salzburg
Austria and they're going in and I and I
start to get cold feet and then this
woman came up to me and I said no I I I
don't have the money and she grabbed the
money and to grab my hands and I went oh
my God oh my God oh my God is this
happening this is happening oh my God oh
my God oh my God we go into this room
there's a single bed there's a sink and
a trash can that's it so then I had to
stand up while taking my clothes off and
I put it on a hook and she goes I was so
nervous that I didn't really feel
anything it's it was a traumatic and a
great exhilarating uh memorable
experience man I've been going back to
Austria ever since I know